[Music]
video game voiceovers traveling to
Vietnam and working with Spielberg
Rachel e cook has been on our screens in
one way or another for decades so where
is she now what are you going to do kill
me with the guitar who's going to go up
there and sing you need me remember
Rachel Lee Cook Rose to stardom with her
portrayal of Lany bogs and she's all
that and then she built on that momentum
2 years later with a liveaction
adaptation of Josie and the Pussycats
the film based on characters from The
Archie comics series and subsequent
hanahar a cartoon show revolves around
the adventures of a fictional band
called the Pussycats cook was cast as
Josie McCoy with Tara Reid and Rosario
Dawson playing band mates Melody
Valentine and Valerie Brown a clever
parody of late '90s pop gloss clashing
with concerns of selling out the flicks
plot centers on the group's Shenanigans
after being discovered by a greedy
record executive in the early 2000s cook
had several high-profile feature films
underperform at the box office like the
Sylvester Stallone vehicle Get Carter
the fear big Tech paranoid Thriller
antitrust and the James Vander be/ Aston
cutcher user Western Texas Rangers today
cats is considered something of a
classic but upon its release it was
similarly perceived as a box office dud
the film also failed to connect with
critics still resting today at a meager
53% score on Rotten Tomatoes like any
good cult classic the film's audience
seems to have steadily caught up with
the clever music heavy film however and
it has since become one of Cook's
signature roles in addition to film cook
has been building her career in
television one of her most memorable
roles on the small screen may have been
Clara wheeler a character in the 2005
Steven Spielberg produced miniseries
into the West premiering on TNT the
series was set in the early 1800s and
told the story of two families one white
and one indigenous American cook would
go on to make guest appearances on Ghost
Whisperer and a couple episodes of the
15th season of Criminal Minds she would
also become a recurring player on the
shows Las Vegas and psych as a working
actor with a career that has spanned
multiple decades naturally cook has
participated in her share of Television
projects that did not pan out in 2010
she signed on to play the lead role in a
fox comedy series called Nirvana but the
series about a pair of indian-american
brothers navigating American
assimilation where cook would have
played one of their girlfriends never
made it past the pilot stage 2 years
later cook could be found in 39 episodes
of perception a TNT series starring Eric
mccormic as a neuros psychiatrist
working with an FBI special agent played
by cook this is your brain
and this is heroin this is what happens
to your brain on heroin expanding her
career Beyond film and television cook
began booking Voice work in 2000 she
played Chelsea Cunningham in two
episodes of Batman Beyond taking over
the role from voice actor IET lenthal
after reprising that role in the film
Batman beyond return of the Joker cook
became the voice of Final Fantasy
character Tia lockart she voiced the
bartender and rebel in various projects
including the animated film Final
Fantasy 7 Advent Children and the video
games durge of Cerberus Final Fantasy 7
Kingdom Hearts 2 and ddia Final Fantasy
NT cook began building a nice side
career in video games portraying jasa
Wilson a Jedi Padawan Who falls to the
dark side and serves the Sith in Star
Wars the Old Republic through her
longtime association with Seth Green's
Adult Swim series Robot Chicken she has
not only provided many voices but also
many Star Wars voices including Luke
Skywalker's ill-fated ant Buu in 2016
cook starred in her first of several
original films for the Hallmark Channel
her Hallmark debut was in summer love as
a widowed mother returning to school in
her mid-30s to accept an internship at a
company where the CEO begins to fall for
her that same year she starred in
another film for Hallmark titled autumn
in the vineyard based on the St helina
Vineyard book series by Marina Adair
Vineyard tells the story of two wine
makers with a past relationship vying
for control of the wine business in the
town of St meline California the
Romantic film spawned two sequels summer
in the vineyard and Valentine in the The
Vineyard cook would go on to star in
several Christmas themed films for
Hallmark including a Blue Ridge Mountain
Christmas Cross Country Christmas and it
is the season to be married in 2018 she
starred in the film Frozen in love which
she also co-wrote and served as a
producer the film follows a hockey
player and a bookstore owner both
struggling with their Public Image
working together to help repair each
other's careers prior to She's All That
cook broke through with a high-profile
1997 anti-heroin PSA for the partnership
for a drug-free americ America an update
of the 1987 frying pan PSA Cook's quasi
sequel had the pre-art him actor
similarly holding up an egg and
explaining that it represents the
viewer's brain rather than simply fry
the egg however Cook's version got
appropriately angsty for a mid90s teen
targeted viewership smashing the egg
with a frying pan wrecking the kitchen
shattering plates wine glasses and more
the PSA made an intention grabbing
effective point about how drugs destroy
lives due to the lasting impact of the
ad cook has Revisited the p SAA multiple
times on Robot Chicken she voiced a
comedic parody smashing even more
objects with a frying pan including her
own head she made a more somber reprisal
in 2017 working with the drug policy
Alliance to critique the intent of her
'90s ad beginning the PSA in similar
fashion this time the white egg gets
switched out for a brown egg and a
subsequent largely animated commentary
on how the so-called waron drugs
unfairly targets people of color in the
realm of Public Service cook might be
best known for her campaigns surrounding
the frying pan PSA but she has done
plenty of other public service work as
well under President Barack Obama cook
was selected as an Arts education
Advocate as part of his champions of
change Arts education program the
program was built to Foster creativity
and a love of the Arts and Humanities
and children and included an alliance
made up of actors teachers principles
organizations and More in 2012 cook
continued her public service work by
launching a scholarship grant program
the program Open to students from ages
14 to 19 helps pay for school related
needs such as classes mentorship
programs and other services that help
students launch a successful career
while cook will likely always be known
for her acting career first and foremost
she has done far more than just
entertain audiences 2021 was a landmark
year in Rachel Lee Cook's career after
22 years she made a return to the
franchise that helped launch her career
this time in a gender swapped remake
titled he's all that like she's all that
the reboot offered a retelling of pigmon
the classic George Bernard Shaw play
relas via Netflix he's all that cast
social media personality Addison Ray as
padet Sawyer a Tik Tok influencer and
popular girl filling the role of Freddy
Prince Jr's Zach Syer from She's All
That after losing her boyfriend and
popularity during a live stream she
makes a bet that she can take an
unpopular boy and make him prom king
enter actor Tanner Buchanan playing the
cook role of ugly duckling although he's
all that is not a direct sequel to the
original film two of the She's All That
stars return to make appearances in the
reboot playing a new character cook is
an Sawyer the mother of padet unlike
Zach and his father from the original
padet and her mother have a very close
relationship though on social media and
at school padet lies about her family's
socioeconomic status in order to seem
richer Anna is a nurse who works long
hours and still struggles to pay the
bills with padet helping out with the
money she earns from her career as a
social media influencer Matthew Lillard
who played Brock Hudson in the original
film also returned this time playing a
principal do you remember the carpet for
the first movie do we have one I don't
know if we had 90% sure we did I thought
it was pretty great over the years cook
has also made it a point to establish
herself as a producer in fact she even
started her own small production company
in 1995 called Ben's sister Productions
the name of the production company is in
reference to her younger brother Ben
Cook producer of the 2021 to 2022
animated series blad Runner Black Lotus
and the upcoming Amazon series Blade
Runner 2099 to date her company has only
produced two films 2001's Tangled and 29
Palms cook continues to produce projects
for herself she has served as producer
on the majority of the movies she
starred in on the hallmar channel as
well as the Netflix original romantic
comedy love guaranteed which cast cook
alongside Damon ways Jr the film tells
the story of a lawyer who takes on a
case from a client looking to sue a
dating website in total cook has
produced 11 features with three more
currently in production the latest
producing SL starring effort for Rachel
Le cook is a tourist's guide to love
which premiered on Netflix in April 23
the story is based on an idea that cook
came up with though she didn't write the
script the film stars cook is a
professional in the tourism industry who
goes undercover as a tourist in Vietnam
in order to learn about the tourism
industry there she meets a local tour
guide with whom she eventually falls in
love the events of the movie primarily
take place in Vietnam and it was filmed
in various cities around the country
Vietnam is just as much of a star as
cook is in a tourist's guy to love the
film's writer arene tronu felt it was
important to have more American films
set in Vietnam that did not revolve
around the Vietnam War or the traumas
left over by the war both cook and her
co-star Scott Lee said that they fell in
love with Vietnam while filming there
and that the culture and food drew them
in